it was a race against time that began
450 kilometers from the campus in Mexico
City or a patient was waiting for the
life-saving operation an ambulance in
Guanajuato rushed the gurukul box
containing the donor heart to all
waiting private jet on landing
police helicopter was standing by at
Mexico City Airport to take the organ to
the desperately ill patient at the
hospital the street outside was turned
into an emergency landing field but then
things went horribly wrong on the last
sprint to the operating room
scooping it off the ground with their
bare hands the men placed the yellow
package containing the heart back in the
cool box leaving a bag of saline drip on
the ground behind them and huge
embarrassment trailing in their wake
yes the hospital the movie the arrival
was a bit scary but fortunately the
operation went well we had the harsh
perfectly protected as it was packed in
three layers the good news is that
despite this potentially heart-stopping
moment excuse the pun the operation was
a success and the patient is doing well
but the to medical staff aren't not fair
and quite so well at the hands of
Mexico's media